oh fill honey you're still up okay how
does this sound Mitchell I love you very
much I not only love you but I admire
you and so are they firing him or
proposing to him honey this was supposed
to be a part-time job he was going to be
done in the summer anyway just be direct
I should have warned him how do you tell
someone they have a reputation for being
lazy Mitchell lazy yeah yeah he handed
in a couple of contracts late but I
didn't want to say anything because he's
practically doing this for free I can't
do this this isn't the face of a
cold-blooded hatchet man
will you do it
hey
oh I'm sorry did we wake you up no it
was up worried about tomorrow my art
teacher acts like I don't exist but I
have one last chance to impress him at
our year-end Art Fair
a few students are doing living versions
of famous paintings I've chosen this one
and I'm using my own family brilliant
right when I told him he said that's
nice Alice
it's been a year
Alice really honey do you think you're
nervous because you got a little crush
on Mr Jarvis no are you sure because
I've seen the wait sounds like you're
the one with the Crush
I've just never had a teacher not like
me before well Miss Davis please she's a
gym teacher she used to teaching what Dr
Seuss is to medicine to think she didn't
like you
you what's your problem nothing I'm just
excited for tomorrow I'm getting metal
at school because I put out a fire
maybe that's what I should be when I
grow up
a professional metal getter
Luke what happened
I don't know I was just walking by and I
smelled flames
I was there
I don't like this we're not supposed to
be in here just keep a lookout we're 10
seconds away from creating plutonium
oh crap we
have
mid
Luke what happened I don't know I was
just walking by and I smelled flames
okay guys you're gonna be dragging
tomorrow if you don't go to bed right
now let's go fine come on Alice
you guys nailed it
dude that was surreal
come on we have a minute to set up
where are Mitchell and cam
you said before about the flag it really
got me thinking I knew you had a
conscience Luke more importantly you've
got a good
you did it yep and thanks to you I had
to move the ceremony to ride under the
flag I'll sign a picture for you
oh there you are I was afraid you
weren't coming it was a discussion if we
weren't going to show up we would have
clearly let you know and not humiliated
you in public if it's any consolation
the lawyer we hired to replace he was
already suing the elevator company oh
you're sitting on my hand be thankful
you have two I almost lost one today oh
stop being such a baby she was nowhere
near that switch
forces down we're about to go on why are
you looking at me am I too loud is that
what everybody thinks what there's a
backstory here you don't want to know
about it I want turkey save your
appetite baby girl and don't forget
afterwards we're going to Lenny's for a
bite to eat more than a bite if you
value my feelings oh great we get to see
Maxine what no Maxine
Maxine love second best hugger in the
world after Mr Burt Reynolds story to
follow guys
over in 90 seconds hold your poses
really want to impress Mr gorgeous
Jarvis shut up
hey Mitch I know this isn't a good time
I just want you to know I'm really I
know Phil you're really sorry okay but
this is gonna take me a little time to
get over all right actually I was going
to say I'm really going to need your
parking pass what our next stage
presentation will be Alex Dunphy's
interpretation of Norman Rockwell's 1943
painting freedom from wand
how do you sleep at night Luke with a
metal around my neck I want turkey oh I
know she doesn't understand that word
Craig McClure control your child cam
it's not that difficult I've raised
three really damn why don't you ask
Haley what time she got home last night
Uncle kale sorry dear collateral damage
what is he talking about your arms are
shaking
you can criticize my parenting oh you
like him but my son just won a medal or
a fire he started is that true
how long is cutting hair you're not
getting that parking pass back I tried
to let you down easy you don't know how
to talk to people Phil it's just like
when Claire didn't even know you dumped
her what when a dead view I didn't dump
her I just talked to her
nose I want turkey
we really are trying to not say that
word
B minus
but there was a silver lining
I expected more Alex
[Music]